hi Gordon I have actually decided to
identify as a man recently my pronouns
are officially your majesty I am a trans
person and would like to weigh in on the
Tweet as it is not offensive as it is
true in a matter of fact welcoming trans
people like myself did make it to
England and are playing all the all all
nations tournament I would like to
recommend myself to be the head of the
board of transgender people thank you
for your consideration I would like to
hear the outcome of this in person
please maybe we could even meet to
discuss representation for people like
myself I just hope they if you guys hear
snoring it's my dog many of you so my
question is okay if there's nothing to
hide bye bye oh I got a response I got a
response from volleyball and something I
said it's the university policy and the
policy of events like this but it's
never enforced it's never enforced
except when it's an agenda that they
don't like